hi I am Joe Russo and I'm Anthony Russo
and we directed Avengers and game and
yes we are still talking about it
now we're here to do Avengers support
[Music]
blue AdBlue blogs so a baby born a few
days before the snap that vanishes
during the snap is technically now five
years old right but it's still a newborn
because it didn't age during the five
years it vanished
also a spider-man 20 now did he age it's
been five years yeah so anybody who did
go away at the snap when they come back
they come back at the moment they went
away so they sort of missed those five
years well everybody who didn't go away
was aging those five years like we all
normally so you wouldn't age a few words
apt out of existence
you would just stop existing and then
when you were brought back you would
begin existing again so no the baby
would not be five years older the baby
would just be the exact same age it was
when it disappeared so hence Tom Holland
his his Peter Parker character would be
the same age that he was when he
disappeared why five years why not ten
why not five months what's the
significance basically we wanted to pick
a period of time that was long enough to
have forced everybody to move on you
could no longer sort of be clinging to
what we should have done how we should
have done it differently maybe we can go
back and stop this we wanted we wanted
everybody to go through a life cycle
where they had to really commit to a to
an existence where this was their new
reality and five years just seemed like
the right amount of time for that this
is from needy unemotional at Sam Keaton
question 44 why did they not show how
Bruce merged his brain with Hulk's movie
we wanted to track how every single one
of the Avengers was moving forward from
the experience of infinity war and
Banner had this very unique experience
where he the opening of infinity war he
loses the fan oh says Hulk later in the
film he loses to Thanos as banner and so
he is left with this reality that you
know neither version of himself could
stop vanos so in the five-year time
elapsed that happens early on an endgame
he so dedicates himself to trying to
better himself so that this never
happens again and that's sort of the
proper motivation for him to finally
figure out how to reconcile the two
sides of himself okay and that was just
our specific needs for our story and now
you have this incredible action figure
it's got some good flex okay quick
question how do you return a soul stone
it's not like black widows soul will be
floating around or going back to her
body and also what was Captain America's
reaction to seeing red skull again so
this is from Moses at makes and mixed
experience so you get an email like you
do on Amazon and then you have to print
up a label put it on the stone stick it
in the mail
it goes back to Reggie's girl fingers
crossed keep your fingers crossed yeah
so seeing Red Skull again I don't know
that's a good question
kept me hopefully cap will remember him
Alex gross why did you kill Tony Stark
pass Victor stone mean mugging hold on
Hulk has a whole healing factor why did
his arm heal the hook has never come up
against every infinity stone in a
gauntlet and the pure power of those
stones and Fanus is nearly invincible
and then he did not heal either so
clearly when you wield the full power of
the Infinity stones it is irreparable
damage to your being if it doesn't even
kill you Daniel alright let's settle
this once and for all who is the most
powerful avenger there seems to be some
sort of pull here where Scarlet Witch
got 23% Captain Marvel got 6% hmm Thor
got 19% and the kid from Iron Man 3 52
percent correct Jeff Fogle how do you
decide what to keep directly from the
comics and what to use as inspiration
a lot of is what you emotionally respond
to in the books how you feel about the
character there's no sort of formula to
why we would pull something from the
books it's really just inspiration it's
like when Winter Soldier we love the
tone of the original run of the books so
we use that tone in the movies sometimes
we'll find a panel that
we love and then we'll try to build a
moment around the panel like we did in
the Civil War but it's it's impossible
to sort of define any sort of scientific
approach to it yeah it often times
sometimes there's something that we like
in the books that doesn't translate
cleanly to him to a modern a movie and
we find another way to interpret it this
is Garrett 51 at amazing Garrett I feel
like the whole reason professor Hulk was
introduced was to force at Mark Ruffalo
in a mocap suit more as a punishment for
leaking spoilers by a Teresa Brothers
this is a very interesting theory it may
be true but we'll never admit to it
being true
cats so who wants to sit for six hours
and watch both Avengers movies back to
back for me to catch Easter eggs not us
we've seen them too many times at rusev
rather serious question
when dr. strange is seeing all the
scenarios for how the war could end does
he see it like a montage or a movie how
do you as the creators see this
happening in his brain this is a great
question and I mean strange has to exert
an immense amount of energy into going
to go into this state and the amount of
time that he's in this state as we know
from from the history in his own
standalone film dr. strange he could be
in that in that state for who knows how
long so it could have taken strange an
immensely long time to actually review
all these scenarios it's to physically
live them you know and then die in each
of them and right before he dies he has
to reset it as we saw at the end of dr.
strange and and do it again and take
copious notes each time he does it great
question that we have thank you Hebrew
sir brothers what happened to the
visions body
that's a good question is a very good
question feels like a story for another
time yeah
curvy llama that is an incredible
Twitter handle if you could be one
avenger who would it be and why powers
good looks personality respond with yes
mine would be female for funny witty
kind carefree powerful
that's very accurate description yeah I
think I take spider-man is my favorite
character growing up I think any any kid
would want to swing on webs or crawl
walls and I love his suit
I'll take Falcon because I am really
interested in what his future as Captain
America will be Sean endo hey rooster
brothers I thought the Avengers weren't
supposed to talk about the future in the
past so I had a professor Hulk talk
about strange giving the time stone of
Fanus to the ancient one conscience may
I mention that that is a Back to the
Future rule that is not applicable in
our universe we're playing by a
different set of rules watch the scene
again with Hulk Rhodey and Paul Rudd
Scott Lang and just listen to how they
describe the rules of time-travel in our
movie there's two scenes that play back
to back sort of described it you know it
gives you everything you need to know
about time travel though you may be
thinking about the the the fact that dr.
strange doesn't want to tell Tony about
what timeline therein as they're going
into the climactic fight with Thanos the
difference between these two situations
are you know when when when smart Hulk
is talking to the ancient one the
ancient one is no longer alive during
the events that they're discussing
whereas Tony is very much involved in
the events that he and he and strange
are talking about so there there's a
little bit of a distinction there and
that's just really talking to someone
about this prior to their death you
don't want to emotionally confuse them
or create a situation where they no
longer want to go through with what
they're supposed to go through
especially when your chances are one in
14 million you have to be very very
careful about not messing it up Daniel
Rickman so much I love Infinity Ward
just rewatched it again the consistency
with the characters power levels all
over the place
Scarlet Witch envisioned two of the most
powerful Avengers lost to aliens and
were saved by Captain America and Black
Widow a human what vision gets skewered
at the very beginning of that fight so
he's
really not functioning at full power he
then becomes a what would we at a
liability in the fight because now
Scarlet Witch has to protect a crippled
vision and it puts her at a disadvantage
in his vision mentions that weapon sort
of has an effect on him that he didn't
expect
so once vision of Wanda are cornered
because vision can't function at that
point cap and Natasha and Falcon oh but
functioning as a unit for three years in
civil war a very tight unit as the three
years of Tears since the Lord I think it
was to the surprise attack proximal
corpus I get the jump on them and and
help a vision Wanda escaped that's how
that scene played out yeah and those are
powerfully powerful aliens but not when
you sneak up on them why did you just
delete a scene like this Shafak Kaka cow
canal cuz a crazy or what Tony deserved
it and they're asking why we deleted the
scene where everyone is kneeling we
deleted it this has seemed on the bonus
features and the home release and that's
why we're deleted it out so we had some
bonus features after the DVDs that's
really important super important next
question Shannon and Rona okay I hope
one day the a truther brothers see my
dedication to Tony Stark and Pepper
Potts this is just from 2018 and all
handmade we're seeing it and it's
incredible and you're amazing
yeah and thank you for being such a huge
fan of Tony and Pepperpot
you know what confused me while watching
any game the fact that there are two
Barton daughters please correct me if
I'm wrong but both of Joe Russo's kids
got to be in the movie one was Lea
Barton I believe and
was Lila but both never shared screen
time yes both my daughters were in the
movie one of them did play Lila Barton
at the beginning of the film and she was
stamped out of existence the other
played a fan of the Hulk and the diner
there completely unconnected characters
they do look a little bit alike so maybe
that was confusing but they are not you
may have been credited as Leah Janna
credits but not as Liam Barton and the
credits so just this is just a random
kid hanging out in a diner up and see
the Hulk and want his autograph
it just happens to share a resemblance
to Lila birth yes all right Nicholas
Bauer
Marissa brothers how come Peter Parker's
friends didn't age in Avengers endgame I
understand why he didn't age but five
years went by for everyone else and
which would be 2023 we see Pete reunite
with that it's cool
surrounded by kids with backpacks that I
missed something well yes also you ned
also went away you know any anybody who
is still the same age as Peter Parker
went away as well and kids with
backpacks in that school are all kids
who went away and now our back at school
or kids who were you know nine years old
when a snap happened and now they're
freshmen so so that have you seen the
new printer Man movie explains it thick
well one problem with endgame is that
Falcon got the shield wedding Bucky get
it
mm Falcon is an amazing character who is
certainly very deserving in the shield
yeah and Bucky you know look at the
thing we've loved exploring about Bucky
is his he has a very complicated history
he has a damaged mind I don't know you
want to hand a very powerful weapon to
somebody who is vulnerable like that
macho man rooster brothers how do you
guys not have any Nova Corp member in a
fight against Thanos love the movie but
just boggles my mind didn't even have to
be Richard Ryder I look closely at that
scene again there and you will see there
are thousands of people yeah you will
see Richard Ryder and
ground of a shot Easter Egg everyone
thank you so much
these were great questions yes yeah
sending in these questions we really
appreciate it and hopefully you got
satisfactory answers yeah and I
hopefully you have answers of your own
see ya